sud, elle est faite en 34 jours.
Mathieu Prost ra
- À 15 000 kilomètr d d'ici,
Caroline Côté vient de réaliser
un rêve et une performance
hors du commun.
de fond avec un traîneau
d'une cinquantaine de kilos,
1130 kilomètres jusqu'au point
le plus au sud possible
34 jours, 2 heures et 53
minutes. C'est quatrjojours
de moins que le précédent
record.
FRÉDÉRIC DION, aventurier
et conférencier
- C'est l'équivalent
de courir un à deux madadadadad.
- Frédéric Dion en sait quelque
chose, lui qui a aussi traversé
l'Antarctique, tracté par
- Sur 55 jours d'expédition,
j'ai fait 9 s s s seulement
de tirage de traineau comme ça,
sans le
pour imaginer l'effort!
- Aucumamamage de son exploit
n'est pour l'instant disponible,
Caroline Côté les rapporte
avec elle pour raconter
les températures autour
de brouillard blanc, où on ne
distingue plus le ciel du sol.
- C'est important pour moi
de gens possible en nature.
- Caroline Côté est une ultra-
marathonnienne et une habituéeis
aussi hostiles que fascinantes.
Comme ici, dans le Svalbard,
aux productions hollywoodiennes,
à part les conditions
de tournage.
- Fait froid quand même,
on va y alle
- Oh ouais, on va y aller, oui.
- Lui, c'e
d'aventures, d'habitude,
et son piriririre tout court.
Être totalement seule
pendanc'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'cs
défis, se rappelle la rameuse
Mylène Paquette.
MYLÈNE PAQUETTE, a traversé
- On est une personne seule
dans un environnement peu
accueillant, assez hostile,
et on est seul, mais c'estacacar
humain qui soutient nos faits
et gestes, pis qui nous motive
à aller de l'avant.àààààààààààà,
après avoir enchaîné 30 à 40
kilomètres par jour, Caroline
Côté reçoit une autre dose
de motivatio l l l l l l l l l à
la station au pôle Sud.
CAROLINE CÔTÉ
- Il va pouvoir m'accueillir
làarriver, là, euh.... quand mêe
assez bientôt j'espère!
- Il lui restait encore de longs
jours sans nuit avant de mettre
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréa